well hello guys hi what were your
thoughts when Jojo rabbit one People's
Choice Award at TIFF just extremely
grateful and love TIFF as a festival in
itself and so just to have people be
extra supportive of it was was brilliant
and just yeah well I think also just
being there on the night when the
audience first saw it the atmosphere was
electric you know we went up on stage we
got standing ovations first time I've
ever standing ovations yeah yeah
and that seemed like it are a harbinger
of something good and positive but
certainly I think we were expecting the
audience award certainly extraordinary
yeah an award like that can cement a
film during award season so are you
thinking about your suits I worry that
I'm not high enough in the cast list to
get an invitation to the Oscars me too I
think maybe like the top three of the
cast to get invited I don't know but
perhaps I'd be happy with an invitation
to say that party the Elton John throws
that's good who would you say the most
fashionable one in the cast me you mean
off camera or on camera off camera oh oh
on camera obviously a festival Finkle is
yeah anything cool and I would say off
camera it's probably gonna be it's
probably gonna be you it's not matter
why it's not me because it's very hard
for me to buy clothes because of six or
seven it's so I can't I'd love to have
you know a real kind of fashionista
approach garish shirts you know just
kind of weird shorts with like shoes I
don't know what fashionable people wear
and it seems like there's that sort of
thing I can do have to just wear what I
can find that fits what a tough life
isn't it thank you movie like Jojo
rabbit so important right now
well obviously there's a growing number
of people who kind of still a dear to
those political beliefs and that's um
sadly still relevant and so the more
that we can
ridicule them the the better I think
and obviously you know satire can be a
powerful tool but I think it can only
really go so far and so if we can kind
of create the impetus to really go and
do some change then that's brilliant
yeah when I first was walking into the
theater to watch this film and I heard
satire World War two Hitler and children
can watch it I thought how in the heck
is that possible
but she did it right um it's it is
fantastic would you say kids can watch
this but I think so I think probably
sort of you know it's like the older
kids but I think yes because I think
that the messages as you saying is it's
just so it's still so important
I still think it's really I think as
people were saying it's still a very
important I think it's like manages to
use humor to sort of bring you in by the
hand and walk you through this very
difficult subject I think that all as
you as you said to the other the message
the optimism of the film is it's really
profound and I think for children as
well I love that okay thank you guys for
your time
you